so I'm Bob Sutton a professor of
management science and engineering at
Stanford that's part of the engineering
school I've been here almost 30 years
some of the kind of stuff
I've done is taught diverse classes and
everything from innovation which is what
my class is about to a leadership to
spreading excellence from those who have
it to those who don't I've taught a lot
of general management classes in terms
of my research I tend to do research on
three different areas the first one is
in general how you manage how you lead
so I've done stuff on turning knowledge
into action I've done books on bosses
good boss bad boss and I wrote a play a
book on workplace jerks that has sort of
a dirty title so that's sort of the
management stuff the second thing that I
work on in my teaching in my research is
on innovation and creativity something
I've taught a lot that's something I've
written about I wrote a book called
weird ideas that work and quite a few
articles I've done a lot of ethnographic
sort of anthropological research on
innovation and the final thing is my
latest sort of passion and excitement
with my colleague huggy Rao
hayagriva Rao at the Stanford Business
School is we're interested in this
challenge that we call scaling up
excellence which is when you've got a
great little company how you make it
into a great big company or in a larger
organization if you've got little
pockets of excellence say pockets of
excellent health care or places where
people are especially innovative how you
spread that around the system so I'm
spending a lot of my time these days
focus on the challenge of spreading
excellence from the few to the many
I think I want to say I say about what
I'm doing you know first of all because
I think the workplace does matter and
second of all I'm an emotional person
and I get to sort of study the emotional
part of life and then and then the other
reason I'm excited about what I'm doing
is to be perfectly honest that I'm
fortunate to be in a workplace where
hardly anybody ever tells me what to do
so that makes me really happy
I guess I'm an innovator although what
is it most of my best friends are
entrepreneurs I guess the reason that
that Amin I'm an innovator rather than
entrepreneur is I think of entrepreneurs
as people who want to start with a small
kernel of something and build it into
something big I kind of just want to do
be left alone to do stuff I think is
cool so I think I'm more of an innovator
even though I kind of like hanging out
with entrepreneurs
fortune should be surrounded with
incredibly hard-working incredibly smart
people especially the students who are
absolutely fantastic they are so smart
they worked so hard it just amazes and
humbles me every day and when Silicon
Valley and Stanford work bastards this
notion that although we come from all
different places we're all sort of
weaving ourselves together in such a way
where everybody is feels great about the
work they're doing they feel pride and
also they sort of feel like they're
developing relationships that will feel
good for a long time